[Music]
injustice jello News justice a jello
submitted by waiting Musti but we dusty
crusty I think it just rhymes doesn't
even musty though for sure yeah Dusty's
easier to get rid of this is a dumb
conversation continue pickles real quick
Bill Cosby was served vanilla pudding as
a part of his first meal behind bars
Wow it's on brand get that brand was it
a joke dude on purpose or were all the
prisoners serve that I don't know that's
a good question that I mentioned that
it's just that they mentioned like does
the article state if he went if he took
a bite and went actually no you know you
got sent to jail right yeah and I know
that but uh this is what I pictured he
goes up to the lunch line right and then
there's an inmate that hates like lady
abusers or whatever and he goes I got
something for you and he pulls out a
[ __ ] jell-o pudding and that's that's
the only thing he has on his tray you
know and it everyone's like eat it food
yeah [ __ ] and then he goes back to his
like like his table no one sits with
them and it he just goes prison guys
across from him like yo I got a jell-o
jiggler for you I remember the jello
jigglers they were so cool I know every
kid wanted that it's just it's just
jello cookie cutter yeah I would never
do it
jello what's it called the [ __ ]
chocolate and vanilla [ __ ] oh yeah she's
so [ __ ] good no other pack something
the packs you have a snack pack snack
bag I don't think it's the jello brand
but they had they make jello makes one
like it the jello chocolate pudding cup
thing yeah that [ __ ] and you eat that
[ __ ] in one spoonful Bob take it out and
just eat it and you're good
subin I've never been hungry than
reading Cosby Court updates yeah because
of the deep-seated way that they
attacked my mind as a child when I see
that man I think of sugary sweets yeah
like I imagined them weakly wake him up
like before all the other prisoners and
be like chocolate cakes for breakfast
and he's like presents the worst like
what because he's got a normal prison
right he's like in a rich folk prison
you drinkin Martha Stewart prison he
doesn't like jordan belfort prison
where's playing [ __ ] tennis in front
of the beach you know some of those
prisons have you seen him like I want to
commit why call it crime so I could just
go there like they live better than I do
you just gotta insert trade bro oh yeah
do that that's the sweet life then I
also was watching a documentary about
how people were trying to get on death
row because it's like that like because
everyone knows they're gonna die it's
just like kind of nicer everyone's like
he's in state prison in Philadelphia and
he got sentenced to 3 to 10 years which
is gonna be about a year and a half I
know what is with that it's like it's
like eight weeks with good with good
behavior or some [ __ ] it's that kind of
[ __ ] I think what annoys me about that
it's a waste of our [ __ ] money dude
just [ __ ] don't put into jail just
because like number one he has no career
his name is tarnished and you're wasting
our [ __ ] money three in ten years is
nothing you know you might as well just
leave him out here's what I gauge it
though cuz what wolves cause be known
for it was drugging people right so can
an 80 year old man still drug people and
have sex with them yes you should
probably go to jail
otherwise I'm on board with you if it's
like if this is an 80 year old man and
he is in a wheelchair and he was a
rapist we know he can't rape I'll say
this though by the time he gets his dick
up there probably wake up it's a race
against the [ __ ] way lewd so here's
some photos of when he was being sent to
prison and handcuffs
dude you're so right that we're looking
at his face it's so hard to look at it I
can't give anyone years old hooding pops
I always think of it this is mug shot
yeah he's blind - isn't he yes he looks
so sad he's blind probably says all
blind like very close to it yeah that's
why his lawyers were trying to get him
to serve his time it like in house
arrest do you think he's sad cuz he got
caught this is this course yeah sad
no dude this guy there were reports that
he was just laughing during the whole
time like he had a smile on his face
like his lawyers they were also laughing
it's probably because like during the
whole process for the cameras they have
to look a certain way but then he has so
many fans no matter where he goes the
lawyers the [ __ ] people in the
audience me but maybe even the judge
everyone's there
like all can I get your autograph ghost
that was dumb does he still deny it I
haven't really been keeping that a
hundred percent still denies it but all
those people he's like no to all of them
like no to you know to you know don't be
72 roses enough to convict him alright I
don't think that's enough the reason why
there was only one that finally stuck
was because she was still within the
statute because everyone else was like
too long ago that's sex this happened in
2004 when she claims that she he gave
her pills and then he sexually assaulted
her and he was still oldest [ __ ] then -
yeah he was still over here just trying
to rape people and he would admit that
[ __ ] under seal so they would they would
go to court and then he would just pay
them off
typically oh but I think this is one of
those situations where too much
spotlight hmm well she's a giant yeah
Wow she could have killed him if she
wanted to
yeah yeah but she was drugged up oh I
know I'm just saying like next time do
you just hug him in the face you know
you know someone that's been in
Hollywood since like the 90s oh hey we
know somebody who is a raper hurt no but
he had a during this when this thing
broke out there was an older makeup
artist and she's like from that era and
then she was just like [ __ ] that guy
like me uh meaning Bill Cosby and he was
like why and it just like that all that
[ __ ] is true like when when I was
younger and I was doing his makeup he
came across and clawed my breasts oh my
god not grabbed but clawed it and said
there's nothing you can do about it Oh
that's what the story that she told him
and then she's like he's gonna you know
he gets he deserves all of this or
whatever that's she had a lot of hate
for him basically it's true too because
like you could never have said anything
back then everyone wouldn't no one will
believe you yeah that's exactly what he
said is like back in a day people were
just untouchable and now like he's like
thank God for Twitter and Internet and
everything because people can really
like there's accountability now yeah you
know youtubers nowadays oh my god it's
there's no kind of ability there for
people who are just entitled it's weird
because you would think that just
because this stuff comes out like it
wouldn't happen but people it still does
consistently every day even have a
friend who does not makeup but she does
like wardrobe [ __ ] but she worked on
something a while back and not even
awhile back like 10 years ago like a
couple years ago or these actors
literally can choose if they want so
this she has to style them right or
whatever right they could literally be
like no I'm not feeling any of this I
don't think I like it I think you suck
at your job and then she'll lose her job
oh yeah for example like she wouldn't
get drinks with him and this is like an
older actor too right so like for him
it's like okay well she's not being
responsive and then she'll try to put
clothes I mean goes no I'm just Tom he's
not Gary Busey I love that man it still
happens now so she has to like a piece
to his ego hang out with him had drinks
with him or whatever if not but he goes
I don't want where today that's sad and
then like production gets like backed up
and then she's to blame for it because
she can't find outfits that look good on
him you know so it's like well what do i
do do bite rat let's do that well I'll
never I'll never work ever again and so
it's those people have to risk their
whole careers yeah to ruin that person's
career but then this person will also
never work again because even if you
take that person down nobody in
Hollywood's gonna hide it it's like a
kamikaze its kamikaze straight up yeah
it's like that old saying you'll never
work in this industry ever again yeah
you'll never work in this city ever
again well that's why even when Harvey
Weinstein got caught he was telling
people hind the scenes that he's making
a comeback he knew how much power he had
exactly he never really believed he's
been doing this [ __ ] since like the 90s
though he was planning on doing a
documentary
come back yeah what he was gonna do a
documentary about this type of [ __ ] and
involve himself Harvey Weinstein or Jake
Paul or you know where he's really
guilty is he the way he looks
no no but here's the thing people are
very primal okay they don't want to
protect a ugly man if you're a gross
ugly man a scary gross ugly man and
you're a sexual predator it's like oh
that's like your double [ __ ] well it's
good that people can believe it like oh
I can see that yes yeah and then they he
fits that bill in face right so it's
like yeah he's a demon to us now put it
in a diff T was like like Chris Pratt
yeah he was someone that was like you
know the girls would be like no or maybe
not even that masking maybe someone that
was more like huge Jason Momoa than
women would be writing him in prison
absolutely let's say it was someone that
was more like a like like everyone's
like dream heartthrob boy Chris Pam
Aquaman a few times he's more of a man
I'm talking about like maybe Justin to
you or someone Oh boyish you know boy
boy and then everyone's gonna be like oh
you know it's okay no they call it an
entitled millennial yeah like weird
weird stories about Justin Bieber - yeah
he's got weird [ __ ] held more people in
saying that he wants to convert them to
Christianity and then he'll try to [ __ ]
them yeah that's just trying to convert
people to Christianity yeah that's all
you got the only person that does that
some weird [ __ ]
well that shit's a hundred percent easy
because we had my friend who's the
assistant right they was she worked for
she worked for I forgot what company was
but either way she had to go to his
house yeah to do whatever signed
paperwork or say [ __ ] and then he would
bring she would watch him bring girls up
and he's reciting Bible verses to them
and he would say do you believe in God
he was straight-up
Assin do you believe in God and then if
not then he would like kick them out but
he that he asked him that and the recent
descriptions of [ __ ] oh my god so
basically he's like a Korean Church guy
basically but that's what he would do he
baptized them
sure this is how he is now but for her
he would make her wait there until he
was finished or he want to sign it until
he felt like it because he she wasn't
being receptive to him so she would just
be sitting there for like hours in his
place for like 10 hours because he has
to sign it or what I forgot what it was
exactly I think it was like visa papers
for him to travel and do like virgins
what I love about about the Pope is that
he would hear the story and he'd be like
okay how are we gonna cover this [ __ ] up
we gotta we gotta cover this [ __ ] up
[Music]